now pretty patel came into her job as
home secretary apologizing for what she
herself called the terrible injustices
of the windrush scandal
but many of the families torn apart part
by the wrongful deportation of people to
the caribbean say they've still not been
compensated for the hurt they were
caused
i'm now joined by a member of the
independent advisory group who delivered
the windrush lessons learned review the
human rights lawyer jacqueline mckenzie
good morning miss mckenzie
i want to come to the crisis in the
channel in a moment but let's
start about uh talking by talking about
the windrush scheme many of those
entitled to compensation from the home
office uh say they've had little or
nothing out of it um
do you know how many were entitled how
many have claimed and
who's got how many have got money out of
this scheme
yes um i i wouldn't say that absolutely
no one has had anything out of it um
but you raise a really important point
in terms of what are the figures that
we're looking at because i don't think
it's very clear the home office has said
that 15 000 people should have availed
themselves of compensation
or being able to make a claim
at the outset though when the scandal
first came to i suppose into the public
domain the figure that we were given was
about 50 000 people 50 000 people
that would avail themselves services of
the windrush task force i don't know
where the 15 000 has come from that's
the starting point
but even if we go
on the basis of the 15 000
i understand just on the 3 000 has made
a claim and just over 800 have had any
payment
the home office say that one of the
reasons for that is that they're not
completely resourced and i say well if
you're not completely resourced for so
few applications
what would have happened
if you'd had anything near what you were
actually expecting
in terms of the payments there's lots of
problems about that
people are very unhappy with some of the
offers particularly for loss of earnings
lost pension
there have been some improvements the
impact of life tariff we think is an
area that has vastly improved there are
preliminary payments which was
introduced by the home secretary in
december 2020
there's still problems with that in that
very few people are actually getting it
but on paper i consider that to be an
improvement
but overall
the processing of the scheme seems
woefully inadequate at the moment
you have a number of clients who are in
this position who haven't got money or
it's been very difficult
tell us what impact this is making on
their lives
the impact is huge because you know
remember that this at the start of this
we found that we've lost jobs people had
lost houses some were detained removed
deported
and if you're now four years after the
scandal
and i know the scheme's only been in
operational compensation scheme that it
is for two and a half years but if
you've been you know traumatized by
being told you're an illegal immigrants
or an illegal migrants in this country
for over four years some for much longer
than that
and you're now having to wait it's an
ordinary time to either have a primary
offer to have your claim accepted or to
be paid out
given that you've already come from a a
place of deprivation remember the cohort
within the windrush generation who are
affected by the scandal are mainly very
deprived and challenged people who have
experienced lower socioeconomic outcomes
um and and and so
this is
unconscionable that they are having you
know to wait so long
what would you like the home secretary
to do about it now
well i mean i gave evidence to the home
affairs committee and one of their
recommendations is that the scheme
should come away from the home office
and go to an independent body
i've now come around i was concerned
myself about delays that that would
pause given how long people have been
waiting at the outset i was one of the
people that gave evidence during the
consultation exercise that said the home
office shouldn't have had the steam in
the first place i mean in effect
they are the people that have carried
out the wrongs i mean it is effectively
they're marking their own homework so
that's pretty um disconcerting to me but
i thought well they've got it where
where where we at um they've made some
improvements but i think
where we are today
the fact that we are seeing so many
people still struggling to even get
through this system the fact that we're
still seeing people in the home office
requesting copious amounts of evidence
it's not necessary asking ridiculous
questions of claimants the fact and the
home affairs committee found this too
that there's considerable mistrust
amongst the community affected with the
home office you know at the same time
they're seeing the deportations seeing
the discussions about refugees and so
forth i think the time has possibly come
now to take the scheme away from him
from the home office who it would go to
is it's a different question
but it would be an independent body you
think i i think it should be an
independent body um one of the problems
at the moment is that the windross
scandal has actually been guarded by
very tiny grassroots organizations
across the country who are helping
people to get status documents to make
exceptional payment claims or to claim
compensation
it isn't the large ngo and there's no
funding for this work and i think you
know
because of that because a very deprived
group of people are finding it difficult
to access the scheme properly it
probably now needs to go to either a
very big ngo or professional body
all right um
you have clients i think who have
taken the route that we've seen a lot of
news about this week across
the channel um
the government wants to make the manner
in which asylum seekers arrive in
britain um part of the judgment uh about
their claim uh for asylum
um they think that that would deter some
people from taking this very dangerous
route do you agree
no i don't agree and i think the
governments are all out of order to even
consider that because people are
entitled to get to a place of safety and
i know it's predicated on the fact that
you know a lot of them are coming from
france
even though you know they've passed
through lots of other countries but i
suppose this current debate is about
people coming from france and making
that perilous 25-mile journey across the
the channel um and it's predicated on
the fact that france is very safe
country
but we do not know what the experiences
are in france in fact just this weekend
i've had friends french lawyers
from paris and colleagues from london
who went to calais to distribute food
aid parcels and we're told it's now
illegal to do that
we have the question of muslim women not
being able to wear the the the knick out
so you know is france a safe country for
everybody it might not be and they are
all we've already rehearsed the reasons
why people choose to come to the uk
because colonial dies language ties
family the reception
but to be clear jacqueline kennedy
you're not really putting
the uh wearing or not wearing of nikub
um
as a reason for people to
risk this
crossing i mean france is
a democratic
law uh
rule of law
country
explain why it is
that people have to risk this crossing
from a country that is just as safe as
britain is yes so i'm certainly not
putting the wearing off the cab as an
explanation
that would probably be relevant to a
very small group of people but you know
we always try to say that countries are
all alike and they're not people have
different experiences people have
different reasons for wanting to move on
to yet another country and they are
entitled to do that that has all sorts
of problems and we are looking at this
in a very basic way um you know what
they come here and so on and there are
all sorts of qualifications i accept you
know are the crossings themselves legal
without authorization if you enter a
report without authorization but article
31 of the refugee convention actually
gives people protection from entering
countries without documentation and
without the rights to do so and and so
people are entitled to make those
crossings now they're making an
extremely perilous journey
we know some of it not all of it but
some of it is fueled by criminal gangs
but you know there aren't any other ways
for a lot of people to do that we know
that the dutch amendment scrapped we
know about problems with dublin because
we've come out because of brexit and one
of the uh this and andy spoke earlier
about the afghan citizens resettlement
scheme when is that going to start we
are getting daily calls from afghans who
want to be able to find a safe route to
claim asylum and they're entitled to do
so
jacqueline mckenzie um it's it's been
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed thank you